who's the greatest musician of all time
would you say we were just off camera
talking about eddie van halen he
unfortunately passed away
who's the greatest musician of all time
yeah
jonathan richmond who's that
it's a weird question so i'm going to
give you a weird answer it's not because
thank you
okay jonathan richard the reason i'm
picking on him is that he had a quote
uh he was the front man of a group
called the modern lovers
and his quote was something like we have
to be prepared
to play music when our instruments are
broken
the electricity's out and it's raining
something like that
and i thought that that quote was very
interesting because what it said was
you have to be able to strip this thing
down farther and farther back to get to
something that is intrinsically musical
so we were having
a conversation just now about virtuosity
and we're talking about eddie van gaal
and his recent passing and
that affected me emotionally i don't
know whether it affected you i was never
a van halen
the group fan but i i revered
eddie van halen's capacity for
innovation just
i saw him like uh you know rodney mullen
the skateboarder i dreamed of having the
two of them on the same podcast just to
talk about what it's like
to totally discontinuously innovate and
you posted a video of spanish fly i
think
and saying like i didn't know the guitar
can make those kinds of sounds like what
is this voodoo
magic is it well this is the thing right
the arpeggios that he did on a single
string
are so fast and the attacks
uh from the hammer-ons when they go
at light speed as he did particularly
and the reason i chose that was is that
i wanted to strip
out the electronics because part of the
claim would be is that he's a rock
musician and a lot of the innovations
had to do with things peculiar
to sort of the electrified setup you
know his his use of the whammy bar for
example or the frankenstrat that he
built
from different pieces right
all of those aspects
in my opinion are just dwarfed by his
innovation and his musicianship
and that's why i chose spanish fly
because everyone of course will go to
something like your eruption or running
with the devil which is the first
things that they heard that let them
know that there was a new force erupting
out of southern california that was
eddie van halen right i mean i just i'm
in love with
i'm in love with the story of it you're
often so poetic
about music like it clearly touches your
soul on some kind of on many levels
what is that is it deeper than just
rocking out with the uh in your
convertible
corvette 69 i imagine eric weinstein is
driving down the
california highways blasting some kind
of music
is it just like being able to be
carefree for moments of time or is there
something more fundamental
that connects to like the theory of
everything
in physics and life and all that how
often do you have the chance for example
to hear mathematics performed as you do
in bach
right like something with that kind of
precision and elegance that can't really
be grasped
where you know uh to go back to leonard
cohen's uh
famous line the baffled king composing
right that's such a good song such a
good song but it's also like
individual verses of that song are
insanely important
um the the baffled king
is how we often make music we don't
really understand what did we just
do that broke that person's heart
sitting on the couch
right and so it's a very strange thing
that you should be able to have
think of it like you're a computer
you've got this weird open music
port you know port 37.8 you know
like it's not even it's not even
supposed to be there and suddenly
somebody starts playing guitar and
they're making you
feel things or you know like in
particular particular instruments like
the violin
uh it's so difficult it's so unforgiving
and when it gives up its secrets it just
you know it
it it wraps its fingers around your
heart and won't let go
sometimes i talk about head heart and
loins when something can grab your head
heart and your loins at the same moment
and integrate them there are very few
opportunities
to live like that and if you think about
eddie van halen uh
you know as far as your head the the
musical innovations
and the fact that he was drawing
directly from the classical canon
um you know really speaks to the idea
that maybe rock
is what um somebody like jimi hendrix
saw it as being you know an infinitely
extensible
medium in terms of heart um
i always notice the smile on his face
it's painful to look at an eddie van
gaal and solo
now like sometimes you'll see the
cigarette dripping off the side of his
mouth and you're like
that's going to kill you and i'm
not even worried about it for you i'm
worried about it for me
you're going to rob i don't even need to
hear you play another note i just like
knowing that you're in the world
that there is somebody that everyone
looks to that no but
i've never heard a guitarist say yeah i
don't know
i think he was okay like i've never just
never heard it you can
hate him but you still think he was a
genius there are very few people like
that in the
in the world and then loins those leaps
that guy was incredibly good looking and
you know skin-tight pants
super athleticism he completely owned
the sexual the male sexuality of the
stage
both being at the completely dominant
you know sort of
mythical alpha male i hate that
expression but there you are
but also this kind of little boy with
this mischievous smirk
and you know the sense that it all came
together
how could you not eat that up you could
just imagine the millions
of like young teenage boys who are just
like playing air guitar in their
in their room just that yeah basically
dreaming of being that kind of god the
the the most perfect example of what a
human being
can be yeah it's fascinating to think it
is and
and then you know as in many of the
cases with these bands
you get these multiple talents in the
same outfit
and i think that the original
configuration with david lee ross i mean
david lee roth is such a hot mess at all
times
i would love you to talk to david lewis
like if the that
that dance would be just gorgeous i
don't know he's can you handle it can
you ride that probably not
yeah probably not because i think he's
very i i get the feeling that he's very
smart
and very uh dysregulated and i don't
know that i could
like like bring him down to earth for a
moment why can i also get pretty
dysregulated
you know yeah and so i don't know i
don't know whether it could be magic it
could be a show i don't know what
you thought of
his appearance on rogan that was an
interesting one i
loved it but joe and that and joe does
this sometimes
sometimes he just sits back and listens
and he just lets
like the music play which works really
well
i think you have a chance to kind of
jump into the chaos
and then you'll just start and the
places you'll go
you may not even talk about music for
like hours it might just go to this
because he i think lives in japan like
there's a weird he's a he's been in
like an emt after he was a rock star he
chose to be kind of like
i don't know you know it it it's like
there's depth to that man that uh that
hasn't been explored
by him either so i that will be an
exciting conversation
you